there have been obviously no shortage of
Trump associates and appointees who have
been tied to Russia and the newest is
hope you're sitting down Donald Trump's
new pick for FBI director to replace
James Comey after all this controversy
about the firing of James Comey over the
investigation into Trump Russia ties and
Trump's personal lawyer in the Russia
matter having Russian clients and the
hearings and the tweets and the
testimony and the cob feffy Trump has
now nominated a new FBI director who is
himself connected to Russia last week
Donald Trump announced on Twitter at
7:44 a.m. in the morning eastern time
that he will be nominating Christopher
Rea as the new FBI director tweeting I
will be nominating Christopher a ray a
man of impeccable credentials to be the
new director of the FBI details to
follow Ray's law firm King & Spalding
represents wait for it two of Russia's
largest state controlled oil companies
Gazprom and the now infamous Rosneft
the Trump Russia blackmail dossier
claimed that rocknest Rosneft CEO Igor
Sechin offered Trump a 19 percent stake
in the company in exchange for trommel
lifting the oppressive sanctions on
Russia the dossier says that this deal
was made between Sechin and Carter page
when page was in Moscow in July of last
year as yet unproven but here's
something that's not just an allegation
here's something that we know to be true
Rosneft started a five hundred billion
dollar oil drilling partnership with
Exxon in 2012 while Trump's Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson was CEO of Exxon
there's no ifs ands or maybes with that
the venture happened to fall through
when former President Obama remember him
placed sanctions on Russia and 2014 so
Rosneft has a number of excellent
reasons to want Donald Trump in office
and have the Russian sanctions lifted we
know that Trump moved quickly to try to
start lifting those sanctions as soon as
he took office so the law firm of
new FBI director appointee handles
Rosneft legal affairs and the law firm
would be in the middle of the
negotiations between Rosneft and exxon
and remember the first name that donald
trump circulated when it comes to the
replacement for the FBI director was joe
lieberman a guy who worked at the same
law firm as donald trump's personal
attorney that's exactly right it is
endless connection and this would
already be enough to be hugely
concerning but it doesn't stop there
because I mentioned that other company
Gazprom they are also represented by
Ray's law firm and according to US State
Department documents leaked in 2010 as
well as the testimony from former
Ukrainian Prime Minister Yulia
Tymoshenko Gazprom is deeply connected
to the highest-ranking Russian crime
boss in the world
semion Mogilevich who allegedly oversees
Gazprom subsidiary that moves oil from
Russia to Ukraine he's described by the
FBI as the most dangerous mobster in the
world and half of that subsidiary is
owned by Ukrainian oligarch Demetriou
firtash a member of Vladimir Putin's
inner circle so what do we have here not
only is donald trump's FBI director pic
connected to russia
through his employer he is connected to
the Russian mob and Vladimir Putin
through his employer a liar a lawyer
talk about a Freudian slip not a liar
necessarily a lawyer who works for the
firm representing Gazprom is being
appointed to lead the u.s. is highest
crime-fighting Bureau which is
conducting the US Justice Department
investigation of potential ties between
Trump and all of these people ray may
have even less motivation than James
Comey to get to the bottom of the Russia
scandal I really don't see Pat at this
point how anyone could be against a
Trump Russia investigation if you're
still hostile to there being an
investigation why if this is all just a
massive series of coincidences that
would be great but an investigation
could do no harm and if your response is
but David the DNC screwed Bernie
yeah the DNC screwed Bernie and it has
nothing to
with this right now and I remember
Republicans saying after Donald Trump
fired James Comey that well he's not
really firing the entire FBI the
investigation will continue but who is
in position of power there really
matters in terms of how aggressively you
investigate absolutely so if he's going
to pick this guy who seems to be just a
hack in his corner I mean it's going to
undermine the investigation and the
house investigation has been undermined
as well yeah that dead investigation has
been a joke just pick somebody who's not
to get connected to Russia Russia Donny
boy